[Music]
she clearly considers this an attempted
rape she believes that if it were not
for the severe intoxication Brett
Kavanaugh she would have been raped she
should not be ignored she should not be
insulted she should be herb associated
we want to go through a process we want
to make sure everything is perfect
everything is just right
I wish the Democrats could have done
this a lot sooner because they had this
information for many months and they
shouldn't have waited too literally the
last days they should have done it a lot
sooner well this is moving forward to a
public hearing just receiving word
within the hour from Senator Grassley
the committee chairman as I said earlier
anyone who comes forward as dr. Ford has
done deserves to be heard my staff has
reached out to dr. Ford to hear her
account and they held a follow-up call
with Judge Cavanaugh this afternoon
unfortunately committee Democrats have
refused to join us in this effort
however to provide ample transparency we
hold we will hold a public hearing
Monday to give these recent allegations
of full airing dr. Ford that he
references is Christine Blasi Ford she
is the accuser who has come out she is a
college professor and she is saying that
she will tell her story publicly up on
Capitol Hill and judge Kavanagh has
pushed back again saying it's all not
true let's bring in our panel Brit Hume
Fox News senior political analyst AV
Stoddard associate editor at
RealClearPolitics Molly Hemingway senior
editor at The Federalist and Christie
our wall politics editor here at Fox
News and all through of the new book
every man a king a short colorful
history of American populist that's a
great read thank you sir
thoughts it's gonna be a real goat
roping this is gonna be a a contentious
fraught space and the Democrats have to
be cognizant of overreaching but the
Republicans have to be very cognizant
about not turning off offending people
like susan collins people like lisa
murkowski whose votes could be affected
here and if they're not seen as being
fair and open and even-handed with this
woman with the accuser that will go very
poorly
maybe this comes in the context of a
midterm election that is looming
obviously
within just a matter of weeks right I
have no idea who to believe and we
without getting into any of that I think
the Democrats you know obviously there
are questions about the senator
Feinstein bringing this up before this
woman came forward and why is that
acceptable and then the Democrats there
was a hearing today that Brett Kavanaugh
was gonna meet with judiciary members or
top staff Democrats so they didn't want
to go why not that said and the White
House responded I thought very well
today and the president and I think it's
very smart that they're having these
open hearings few hours ago we thought
that the Senate Majority Leader was
resisting this idea and that would have
been a huge mistake that said there is
still time for the Republicans on that
committee or in leadership to mess this
up and if they do not handle I'm going
to echo what Chris said if they do not
handle this well and give this woman her
due
they will face a stampede on November
6th and possibly a Democratic Senate and
it's just a mistake they don't want to
make right well it looks to me from what
we know now as if somebody's gonna have
to corroborate their own version of
events somehow or we're gonna end up
with it he said she said and no one will
be able to say the others lying or
telling the truth and the last two he
says here there's another person if
that's true that is true mark judge was
a alleged to have been in the room and
he said he didn't remember anything like
that happening so that would be two
against one of course he's being
attacked because he's you know had
alcohol issues through the years so you
can imagine how agree that will get but
if it comes down to that where it's you
know can't be proven or disproven the
last time that happened was the was was
Anita Hill in Clarence Thomas
it was never successfully established
that she was telling the truth or that
he was in denying her allegations of
improper sexual advances to her and he
got confirmed and he got confirmed I
might add by a Senate that was 56 44
Democrat as opposed to this one which
was narrowly Republican but they were
back in those days Brett as you know I'm
sure there were a lot of there were a
lot of centrist Democrats there aren't
very many of the
Republicans either the red Cavanaugh has
now put out a couple of really vigorous
defense and and denials here he said
this is a completely false allegation
I've never done anything like what the
accuser describes to her or to anyone
because this never happened I had no
idea who was making this accusation
until she identified herself yesterday I
am willing to talk to the Senate
Judiciary Committee in any way the
committee deems appropriate to refute
this allegation from 36 years ago and
defend my integrity now he says he
wasn't even at that party right this is
why in addition to the political
implications I think this is a really
interesting question of whether we want
to be the type of society that handles
disputes in this way this is an
allegation that was made it's at odds
with what a gajillion people have said
about Brett Kavanaugh including women he
dated at the time at the same time this
was alleged to have happened and in
college the way it went down as a be
noted is very curious Dianne Feinstein
chose not to bring it up at any of the
many times she could have done it behind
closed doors when she was talking to him
privately only orchestrating a big
public leak that makes it seem like
she's less interested in justice than
using this as a political cudgel and of
course Democrats began this whole
process by saying they would do
literally whatever it took to stop this
nomination and so I think that there's a
additional question about whether we
think it's appropriate that an
allegation that can be neither proven
nor disproven should be the basis for
determining who goes on the Supreme
Court or whether we should have a much
higher standard for rule of law and how
we handle important things like Supreme
Court nomination here is the Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer on this
woman's credibility
I believe she's credible a lot of my
Republican friends don't what are they
afraid of they afraid that she might be
very persuasive well if she is it's a
whole different ball game here isn't it
Chris I mentioned with Jonathan Turley
earlier that if it goes down this road
and the nominations pulled will
Democrats start impeachment on judge
Brett Kavanaugh because if he's not
eligible as a as they believe a sexual
assault perpetrator for the Supreme
Court how is he eligible for the second
as court in the land I'm sure they would
but there is a serious consideration for
Democrats politically here that I don't
think they have wrapped their brains
around completely if they did succeed in
getting the cabin on nomination taken
down and there is a vacancy on the
Supreme Court on Election Day
and Joe Manchin and Claire McCaskill
will say come on Schumer like you're not
helping us here nobody more than those
red state Democrats wants this
nomination complete done and moved on
from if this lingers over it has
political consequences for them does
this open up though the possibility that
they now have a free vote to vote
against Kavanagh and maybe they were
going to vote yes but now they don't
I've long believed that you'd get some
Democrats if no Republicans broke I'd
still think that's a distinct
possibility if if all the Republicans
stay together and the nominee is thereby
guaranteed to be confirmed
I'm sure Schumer will privately say to
the wavering Democrats that are in tough
reelection fights this year because of
the state's air in you go ahead and
catch the boat you needed to take for
your purposes of your reelection but if
a Republican or two cracks I don't think
this nomination is gonna be saved by
Democrats I don't think there's a
slightest chance of that